sous les fenêtres de la préfecture de
versailles le message est repris en
choeur par une centaine de personnes à
l'appel de nombreuses associations et
mouvements locaux les manifestants
étaient réunis pour réclamer plus de
places d'hébergement d'urgence
actuellement 70 familles dorment dans la
rue dans les yvelines hier par le jour
il n'ya pas ya pas qu'à la veille au
caire pour 6 buts et pour dormir
les enfants ont besoin à l'elite europe
comme tout le monde ils ont besoin de
dormir comme commun c'est comme prendre
tout le monde
c'est insupportable à notre époque voilà
or il y aurait certainement moyen
d'augmenter le nombre de logements
d'accueil et surtout d accueil pérenne
lancé à l'initiative d'une trentaine de
mouvements yvelinois l'eau rassemblement
fait suite à l'évacuation ces dernières
semaines de plusieurs campements sur le
département
comme à saint quentin en yvelines début
octobre pour tenter de trouver une
solution le préfet des yvelines a reçu
pendant plus d'une heure une délégation
de huit personnes
on n'attendait pas forcément non plus de
l'état tout de suite que je trouve des
places d'hébergement
je crois qu'il nous a montré qu'il avait
le souci de l'hébergement ce qui nous
interpelle plus c'est là
l'incohérence de ce démantèlement de
bidonvilles qui pour certains ne sont
pas dans un état d'insalubrité tels que
on met les gens à la rue après les avoir
hébergé pendant quinze jours à l'hôtel
pour cet hiver la préfecture a annoncé
l'ouverture supplémentaire de 240 places
d'hébergement un plan global sera
également présentée l'an prochain